a great tasting salad starts with
fantastic salad leaves and when it comes
to all things green there's little dr
steve rothol doesn't know
i think i am obsessed with salad i'm
obsessed primarily with watercress that
that's in my heart because you know i've
got a phd in watercress
a doctorate in salad we should all take
a leaf out of his book then he's not
only been studying salad leaves for over
30 years he's been growing them so he
really knows he's rocket from his
romaine
there are literally thousands of
varieties of salad things like batavian
lettuce red veined spinach wild rocket
sorrel we grow
virtually everything outdoors and and we
follow the seasons so we're not forcing
the leaves we don't give them too much
fertilizer or irrigation we try to grow
them a little bit slower and that's the
way to get the best flavor and the best
quality of leaf we'll harvest the crop
cut it in the morning and it's then on
the road going out to customers to be on
the shelf the next day
this is a great leaf baby leaf spinach
and we call it baby leaf yeah quite
literally because we cut it when it's
still at a baby stage
these are baby pea shoots we'll put
something like three or four hundred pea
seeds into the seed bed and then in as
little as 12 14 days they've grown to a
sort of a crop like this they've got the
flavor of fresh peas a bit of sweetness
and they've got a really nice soft
velvety leaf texture
this is baby watercress which is my
favorite salad crop of them all
watercress is special because by
definition it's grown in pure flowing
water fresh watercress has got that
fantastic pungent peppery flavour
in victorian london it was known as poor
man's bread whereby a lot of workers
would start the day with a watercress
sandwich and if they couldn't afford
bread they just ate the watercress
straight
it is amazing full of flavor
i can't eat enough salad obsessed
steve's spot on there's hundreds of
salad leaves available with different
textures tastes and colors here are five
my favorite everyday salad leaves and
don't forget some of them are delicious
cooked too
little gem sweet and crisp and an
amazingly dense heart these mini cos
lettuces are great simply braised in the
oven or use the leaves as scoops for a
delicious chili beef filling
[Music]
mustard leaves pungent spicy and full of
vitamin c these are a staple in asian
dishes and are fantastic stir-fried or
steamed
lambs leaf full of tangy flavour and
with incredible springy stems great for
hearty robust salads or simply paired
with fish for a healthier simple supper
rocket these distinctive peppery leaves
are actually classed as a herb and are
perfect in soups or with fruits and are
full of iron
finely chicory or endive these tightly
packed red and white leaves have a
deliciously bitter taste and are great
wrapped in ham or alongside sharp blue
cheeses
i think when you're shopping for salads
you can just shop with your eyes if it
looks fresh and healthy tasty it is you
want to look for bright colors i like to
see leaves with a bit of moisture on
them
sounds like to be kept cold and moist
basically so when you buy a pack of
salad put it in the fridge and if you
don't use it all in one go
roll up the bag to exclude surplus air
put it back in the fridge keep it cold
there's so much choice variety out there
i really do think people should be more
adventurous in their choice of salads
here both what they choose to try and
eat and and what they do with them
so get yourself some ingredients use
them boldly and your studded leaves can
really take center stage
green papaya salad this is a great salad
to serve at a party it's delicious and
robust enough to last the whole evening
without wilting
first off
these are a little dried shrimp you can
buy them anywhere
they smell almost sort of of the seabed
into the pestle mulch for this salad
inspired by my travels across thailand
i'm starting by making a wonderfully
spicy paste a little salt in there
in
just break them up this paste is like a
staple ingredient in thailand that's
what we're looking for almost it's like
a powder
right next just one clove of garlic
slice up the garlic
and get that into the pest and water
bird's eye chili incredibly hot powerful
but wow
it does give an amazing kick to the
paste
in
to the mix
now a couple of tablespoons of brown
caster sugar that softens the blow with
a chilli and then just to give that nice
sour taste a little bit of hot water
into this
tamarind paste it's really tart but
sweet paste
one tablespoon in
fish sauce
now it's got that almost sort of pickly
smell slightly salty but the flavor is
intense two tablespoons in bring that
together
and give it a really good mix
some lime juice
in half
another touch of tartness
the paste is nice and thick and
fragrant but it's got the heat the
sourness the tartness
incredible
green papaya stand it up
give it a little peel you can find green
papaya and local asian shops and bigger
supermarkets and as it doesn't weld like
more delicate veg it's perfect for
robust salads like this i grate it
look
that's what i want these
thin slithers
next a nice rich
sweet banana shalom
[Music]
nice
some carrot
carrot gives it another texture
now little that and mix it
[Music]
finish that off with thai basil and
fresh coriander
thai basil is a
much more fragrant
basil it's stronger and it's slightly
thicker as well
like papaya and tamarind paste you can
get thai basil in good supermarkets and
independent asian stores but normal
basil works well too
next prepare the crunchy topping
pan on and toast some peanuts
chop the nuts but it gives a really nice
crunch
in they go
roll them around the pan
gas off
and just stick them out
now for the exciting palm i'm gonna
dress the salad
nice spoon of dressing in to the papaya
mix that in
and then finally
a nice general sprinkling
roasted nuts
and that is one delicious very fragrant
very robust
green papaya salad
so easy to make and guaranteed not to go
limp a perfect party salad
and with such incredible colors textures
and bold exciting flavors it's sure to
grab your guests attention
when you're putting together a feast for
the family or friends it's great to have
some bulletproof salads in your cooking
repertoire here are three more of my
favorites to set you up
first my delicious chopped salad
slice cherry tomatoes in half
and add to the bowl
along with chopped red pepper
and finely diced shallots
next slice salami into strips
and add
follow with nutty chickpeas
and smooth edam cheese cut into
matchsticks
building up different tastes textures
and flavors as you go
next add chicory for a deliciously
bitter bite
then chop crisp romaine lettuce
and add
for the dressing
finely chop garlic
add cherry vinegar
and shake our spicy worcestershire sauce
cast the sugar
and olive oil
then simply whisk
pour the dressing over the salad and mix
so that everything is thoroughly coated
finally sprinkle with dried oregano for
an aromatic finish
a salad so easy if you can chop you can
make it with such delicious results it
has to be tasted to be believed
[Music]
my next simple salad that's perfect for
a party is green bean salad with mustard
dressing
[Music]
for the dressing wrap a whole bulb of
garlic in foil
and roast it in a hot oven
[Music]
next add top and tail green beans to
salted boiling water
and cook for just a couple of minutes
this is called blanching and keeps the
beans deliciously crunchy
[Music]
strain the beans
and refresh in cold water this stops the
cooking process so they stay crisp and
green
[Music]
next remove your garlic from the oven
[Music]
cut off the head
and squeeze out all the glorious garlic
which has gone creamy mellow and divine
in the oven
then simply add sharp white wine vinegar
a dollop of dijon mustard
and sweet runny honey
season
and pour in a good glug of olive oil
then whisk
[Music]
add the crunchy blanched green beans
and top with toasted almonds for a
lovely nutty note and crunchy texture
mix well
and serve
heavenly mustard vinaigrette with a hit
of mellow roast garlic stunning green
beans dressed to perfection
[Music]
my next salad that's great for any big
bash is roasted red pepper lentil and
herb salad
[Music]
add pre lentils to vegetable stock
along with a bay leaf and boil for 15
minutes
pre lentils are perfect for sellers they
have a great meaty flavor and a
delicious bite for texture
[Music]
next chop sweet red peppers
and place on a baking tray
along with diced courgette
drizzle over olive oil
season
and roast in a hot oven
to assemble the salad
place the drain lentils in a large bowl
then add olive oil
[Music]
and chop some blush tomatoes
[Music]
take the roasted red peppers and
courgettes from the oven and add
along with chopped avocado as its
delicious creamy flesh gives the salad a
lovely contrast
[Music]
season
then for a big herby hit chop a handful
of chives and basil
and add
squeeze over lemon juice
and mix
earthy aromatic and packed full of
goodness absolutely stunning serve with
roasted meats and fish or perfect eaten
just by
itself three incredible salads all
bursting with flavor color and health so
quick and easy to prep and utterly
delicious you'll be making them every
day not just on a special occasion
nice
you